it was really good man you know I just
definitely
enjoyed myself it's like going to a high
school reunion you know what I'm saying
seeing all the people that you used to
work with it's been great
[Music]
I feel familiar very familiar especially
with that dude back there
I ain't never been to a high school
reunion I've been and then
I haven't been either clay I haven't
been either okay that's it
was a stage again
um it's a very different show nowadays
it is a very different show it feels
like the American Music Awards now yeah
it's like a con it was a it's a concert
it's a real production the way this show
is done now we didn't have a band
remember that we did not have a band it
was all tracks so you know this was this
was I enjoyed this to play with the band
tonight huh like I tell you when you
guys interviewed each other for us that
was TV gold truly I feel like we usually
you can just bring us back and we could
do it on a regular basis we have to
cover America uh American Idol we thank
you Entertainment Tonight thank you for
having us
listen there is no time like this time
and this time it's Clay's time hi clay
how are you I'm doing well how about
yourself did you enjoy the interview I
mean excuse me the the performance that
you had today I enjoyed it more because
I got to sing with you well listen it's
a pleasure to sing with me I tell you
okay I can tell y'all have some fun on
tour huh
you're gonna have to make this an annual
thing I think I think the whole thing's
lasting a year so you can't do it an
annual thing if it lasts all year not
tired of each other yet oh yeah sure we
are
now you did tell us that Ryan
accidentally spoiled the winner for you
your guys's season you saw it on the
card right I did that is such old news
so it was 20 year old news but do you
think he's going to learn his lesson
tonight no doubt Ryan is a consummate
Professor he doesn't he has no he does
no need for cards anymore he was he was
he was green back there it was early it
was his first season hosting by himself
remember jacket is just hella
distracting right now like it's just
it's too much sequence going all right I
know I look like six feet and Roy
the tiger yeah
obviously you guys know better than
anybody what this journey is like
especially post Idol what advice do you
have for these guys stay focused it's a
lot of work you know I mean I just told
a young man backstage just you know it
starts today you know like all this all
this seems like a lot but it's nothing
compared to what he has in front of him
so just stay focused and get the job
there yeah we've been we we always talk
to each other about how idle for us was
more of a
like it was really the most brilliant
educational experience and and as I said
to one of them today you know when you
go to college you get a great education
but you don't automatically get a job
afterwards you have to do the work to
make sure that you you get the job so
Reuben's right the work starts
tomorrow they can have tonight they
should enjoy it savor it but the work
starts tomorrow
foreign